and why beholdest thou the mote that is
in thy brother's eye but considerest not
the beam that is in thine own eye or how
will you say to thy brother let me pull
out the mote out of thine eye and behold
a beam is in thine own eye well you
might be wondering what a beam is and a
mote is a dust speck and a beam is a
very large piece of lumber and so the
issue is not so much the blindness of
others even though there's as much
blindness among others as there is as
there is for you but the issue here the
advice here the description here is you
should be concerned about what's
interfering with your own vision first
and you should leave other people the
hell alone in relationship to that and
so if you're a mode of being in the
world is if you would just act better
things would improve for me or if you
identify the evil and the catastrophe is
something that's outside that someone
else needs to fix or that someone's
response someone else is responsible for
then then you're not going to fix that
and you're going to remain blind to the
things that you're doing and not doing
that make things not go well and so it's
just better to think
alright I'm probably blind in many many
ways and maybe there are some ways that
I could rectify that because it's highly
probable that you're blind in all sorts
of ways I mean it's in fact it's
virtually certain and so it's just more
useful to think how is it that I'm wrong
in this situation I'll tell you
something that I learned to do when I
was arguing with my wife which happened
quite frequently because when you
actually communicate with people you
find out that there's many things that
you don't agree on and that's because
you're actually different creatures and
so if you're actually going to have a
truthful conversation then you're going
to find out that you don't see things
the same way and then you can either
pretend that that's not the case and
gloss over it and then end up in a 30
year silent war or you can
or you can have the damn fight when you
need to have it and see if you could
straighten it out so now and then we'd
get in a situation where we were at
loggerheads we couldn't move and you
know it would spiral up into hate speech
let's say cuz yeah
everyone laughs because they know they
manifest plenty of hate speech towards
those they love so one of the things we
learned to do was when we hit an impasse
was to separate and to go our own ways
and to go sit and think okay look we're
at this unpleasant situation we can't
figure out how to move forward I'd
always think of course it's her fault
obviously it's her fault least 95
percent but maybe there was something I
did that contributed like 5 percent to
it and so I would sit and think and ask
myself a question which was is there
anything I did in the last six months
that increased the probability that this
impasse would manifest itself and I'll
tell you you have no idea how fast your
mind will generate an answer to a
question like that because there's
undoubtedly some idiotic thing that you
did that you know that you remember that
increase the probability that you're
going to have your hands around the
throat of the person that you love and
then you can go tell them that and then
you can have a conversation especially
if they do the same thing say look you
know here's how I'm an idiot in this
situation now the person says well yeah
here's how I'm an idiot and then your
two idiots and then maybe you can have a
conversation so thou hypocrite first
cast out the beam of light out of thine
own eye and then shalt thou see clearly
to cast out the mote of thy brother's
eye that's a hard argue with that